et bien aujourd'hui on se retrouve de
nouveau sur turbo 10 moan parce que tout
comme pour god simulateur guèye plein de
contenus qui ont été créés par les
joueurs et surtout des maps dont je
comprends qu'on les teste ensemble on va
commencer avec crash statique cas pas au
ca fait plus penser aux joues tu mets
les pièces la fête foraine et où tu
perds 800 euros la minute
daube évidemment aux 17 hommes watts le
zimbawe ça existe des routes comme ça
c'est dans aucun sens ok on y va en mode
mobile stakes est parti alors au la
déception
l'espagne est là tout seul comme ça bon
j'ai compris j'ai compris le message
ouais bah tu as donc de boost incroyable
la chaux-de-fonds et bien non comme ça
c'est naze ah oui j'avais oublié
allez on y va on salue pas lui nickel
nickel il manque actuellement toutes les
parties
encore un truc oh non mais on pc va
exploser on paie ses attentes
c'est un grand malade le mec a fait
cette bape et m'ont cherché un ouh là là
là un gros problème déjà d'entrée dieu
voilà d'accord la luge d'été édition
proche du corps mais j'vais pas encore
arrivé qu'un accident de loup ça c'est
le truc que ton pc ne supporte pas que
tu as une image toutes les 20 secondes
ça suffit ça suffit [ __ ] ou pc va
péter alors on y va on y va on y va
mais doux
renvoie mon camion beach voilà on a un
chamallow maintenant la course et ça tu
ne gagneras jamais tu as gagné avec cheb
anouar haddam pc moi je propose qu'on
change de mains pendant qu'on paie c'est
un brûlot vraiment au québec elle ok
j'ai tenté un truc j'ai sûrement pas du
tout marché dit qu'elle en a raté le
boost dicale d'accord classé hockey à
prendre sa maison mais reste accroché
j'ai compris j'ai compris où il veut en
venir
on va voir la star va rester accroché
mais il reste accroché en plus mais se
fout de ma gueule
on y va on y va et c'est la roue en mer
rouge à mes droits les trucks va droite
ou trois mais non au moins se gavent lui
un truc qui s'arrête à un centimètre de
la route quoi c'est parti [ __ ] mais
c'est au oui ça ça sert à créer un
attentat ça mais on va redonner sa
liberté à ce petit oiseau prends ton
avant le jeune petit oiseau on a fait un
gros sur place ah oui allez on va le
toit non pas par là la vitesse il va
tomber abandon mais c'est sûr aller au
continuo continue t'as pas peur tu ne
crains rien trop forts pour eux tu
passes le tremplin
tu passes mal tremplin tu as une [ __ ]
de serpillière comme et regarde et vois
ça
ici on fait juste un vieux clic la lente
ah non je suis des goûts puisque c'est
possible oui mon gars alors qu'elle
était la probabilité que je ne prenne
aucune peur de voitures mais d'une
malédiction là tout ce qu'on veut c'est
qu'ils prennent une voiture en pleine
phase tu peux faire ça pour moi quand
même or ça me fait plaisir
ta jolie moignon maintenant il plaît pas
l'unique essai des envies rennais qui
sait les voitures bien sacro quoi au la
nullité peut-être non mais regardez sa
tête un millimètre ta maison trop de
chance aujourd'hui et je sais pas quel
âge vous fais un bon gros camions
le caddie le caddie attention le
véhicule au moins fiables du monde où
suis je suis je suis je suis un camion
qui a je suis là très bien nickel
leur taux de chômage ou allez allez le
caddie voulais pas y aller je tremble de
peur au revoir qui dit à quoi sert cet
obstacle
j'étais sûr j'avais passé entre les deux
tremplins ni pourquoi arrêt mais c'est
pas l'heure de sortir ton pied c'est
l'heure de te manger une voiture dans la
face aux expliquez moi mais non mais
chemin sans troller les cas trop de
voitures quoi cette malchance pour le
tente au dauphin est ce que quelqu'un y
croient ne serait ce qu'une seule
seconde
elles sont même pas tombé sur juste
écarté comme pour me dire donc je passe
fait ce point je passerai ce pont non
non j'ai ramassé est surtout chine coûte
que coûte
hop la gym vaincra toujours de graves
dégâts même quand je meurs l'agent dit
que leur fils ait vu des 45 lors du 4e
art qui est ce qu'ils ont fait regardez
moi bien non il fallait prendre à gauche
en fait aux îles veine georges mal flic
chargé haute
c'est pas sympa j'en appelle aux
pouvoirs du 4 4
ok donc là c'est sympa en freestyle
nickel bombe à jarden c'est bon je te
laisse bonne journée ne lui veux pas y
aller qui suscite cette map
l'oiseau se venge de tous ces moments
passés à rater ok nickel dont tu peux me
dire d'aller se faire [ __ ] et revient
même à dieu tout sept minutes passées à
le regarder pas volé mon dieu regardez
le comme il allait rendre heureux
ah non les sites risque d'un coup
j'étais séduit qu'un dock 80 de sumo
quoi maximus c'est bien maximus maximum
espaces on est ensemble on est dans le
fort et juste a tué notre job qui
dépasse et baxi bus tu arrêtes il est un
peu lâché je veux juste un qi john qui
ressort d'un café j'ai fait du
skateboard à plat ventre parce que mon
grand père m'a appris bizarrement
tellement bien appris que je ferai avec
ma jambe qu'à chaque fois que je fais du
ce catcheur entre les jambes brûlées
gros skateboard comme non jeter mes gars
dit
sans moi la ville qu'a dit sur moi me
laisse pas tomber au nom au plus tu
m'abandonnes les 6 me les oiseaux oui
c'est moins sympa très stylée en eau j
mais c'est vrai mais bravo non mais
comme citoyen n'a pas de cerveau et
klose n'a pas de cerveau non parce que
leurs routes sont soulevés avec la
vitesse je ne les prend pas mais non
mais j'y crois pas messi mais c'est une
blague
c'est ça être anglais toi abréger ses
souffrances et resserre un peu les
jambes
yes we go slider et la télé sur la moto
et bim canard mur haut il a mis des
coeurs et de même ge qui ferait voir un
vélo qui [ __ ] tout seul vous aussi en
fait ils pédalent pas tout seul il est
possédé
c'est le début d'une grande aventure
vers l'infini nickel donc tu veux faire
laventure seul quad mais je retiens je
viens d'aller à la plage c'est vraiment
elle va juste elle va déposer sur le
pont puis il yal elle rentre à la maison
c'est pas grave j'aime bien je suis bien
ici
elle et je lui dis au revoir bah oui on
est mignon quand on va y arriver j'ai
confiance en nous [ __ ] oui oui qu'est
c'est beau oui encore ou sur les
voitures a actuellement tout conducteur
sont décédés l hôtel spa drift obile kif
c'est la fête aujourd'hui et voilà les
gens c'est déjà fin de cette deuxième
vidéo sur turbo discount j'espère que ça
vous aura plu si c'est le cas n'hésitez
pas aimé la vidéo on se retrouve très
bientôt d'une nouvelle vidéo tu as tout
le monde puisse non je déconne
le fait